Bonjour les ptit's potes, alors déjà merci car vous êtes désormais 8 millions d'abonnés a ma chaîne youtube.
Champagne !!
*Musique de fête*
Alors ça fait super longtemps que j'attends de vous faire cette vidéo
parce qu'elle correspond pour moi à près de trois ans de travail
j'suis donc hyper content et hyper fier de vous présenter
*roulement de tambours*
le dvd de  mon spectacle
*Musique de fête*
Et son calepin, voilà
Ouais bon les confettis on va pas le faire à chaque fois, hein.
*Musique de rock*
Moi souvent les gens quand ils me voient dans la vraie vie, t'sais
Ils savent qu'ils m'ont vu quelque part, mais ils savent plus trop où.
La dernière fois y a un mec qui m'as fait euh...
"Eh c'est toi euh... internet ? "
*rires*
C'est ça, je suis internet.
Et ça c'est mon pote Wi-Fi
*rires*
Alors vous avez été 400 000
à venir me voir dans plus de 300 dates en France
Mais aussi en Belgique, en Suisse, au Maroc
et au Québec, tabernacle
C'est le même spectacle que je joue depuis le début, hein y'en a qu'un seul, c'est celui-ci.
Et maintenant ce spectacle est là-dessus.
Les gens me demandent toujours "est-ce que ton chat dans tes vidéos, c'est ton vrai chat ? "
*rires*
Bah nan, c'est un comédien !
Alors j'ai été mis en scène par un monsieur qui s'appelle Kader Aoun
Je suis hyper fier d'avoir travailler avec lui parce que,
tout ce qu'il a fait dans sa carrière bah, c'est mes références de quand j'étais p'tit
Il a mis en scène les deux spectacles cultes de Jamel
Il a créé le Jamel Comedy Club,
Il a créé le Burger Quiz,
Il a créé H et plein d'autres trucs pourries mais ça il m'a demander de... de pas en parler.
Bon, c'est distribué par TF1, moi je m'y connais pas trop, très honnêtement.
Mais c'est quand même assez flatteur de me dire que j'ai quand même le même distributeur que Gad Elmaleh,
Florence Foresti, et Maya L'Abeille
Alors on a filmé le spectacle à La Cigale, à Paris.
Euh... Alors pourquoi La Cigale ?
Tout simplement parce que c'est la première grosse salle parisienne dans laquelle je l'ai joué et
Pour moi c'était donc assez symbolique.
Alors pour le décor, j'avais pas envie d'avoir un vieux fond noir tout neutre,
J'voulais avoir ma petite touche à moi, avoir un décor bah, qui me ressemble
Alors j'ai carrément travaillé avec une entreprise de décoration
On a dessiné des croquis, puis en 3D un appart' inspiré du mien
avec dedans des objets qui m'ont vraiment appartenus
et puis une lumière un peu intimiste
pour donner l'impression d'être dans mon univers quand je suis sur scène.
Moi je suis pas un mec issu de la culture e-pop tu vois
j'ai pas la streep craig
Il se trouve que, récemment, je me suis retrouvé embarqué dans une soirée e-pop.
avec un pote. Soirée cauchemardesque.
Déjà on arrive devant la boîte e-pop
Le vigile il fait "Attendez les gars, vous êtes deux, vous êtes pas accompagnés.
Partez et revenez avec quatre filles, et peut être que vous rentrerez. "
J'suis en train de lui faire : attends mec, on part et on trouve quatre filles, on revient pas...
*rires*
C'est notre rêve ! Ça n'arrivera jamais !
Par exemple y a des potes, qui nous ont fait rentrer tu vois,
dans cette boîte je me suis tapé la honte de ma life (vie)
Tous les mecs étaient ultra stylés e-pop,
tous sur-baraqués, sur-tatoués,
des petites bagues aux doigts. Y a des mecs qui arrivaient à rester virils, en portant deux boucles d'oreilles.
euh, t'sais moi je mets deux boucles d'oreilles... *rires*
...on est d'accord.*rires*
Je mets un pied dehors, je me fais violé
Et tous les mecs étaient hyper bien habillés e-pop
ils avaient des longs t-shirt de la NBA qui vont jusqu'aux genoux.
Moi je mets ça on dirait une robe de chambre c'est sûr. *rires*
"Oui tout le monde, je vais me coucher, au revoir ! "
Ils arrêtaient pas de s'appeler "frère" entre eux.
"Eh frère ! Bien ou bien frère ? Ça va frère ? "
Moi je peux pas dire "frère" avec mon visage.
Moi si je dis frère, on dirait que je suis monastère.
*rires*
"Frère Benoît ! *rires* Frère Benoît !
Je vais prier un peu à l'église : chaussée au moine ! "
C'est souvent après le spectacle, les gens me font des petits commentaires.
Alors c'est toujours intéressant à entendre et plutôt agréable
Sauf quand c'est ce que j'appelle : un Faux Compliment
Véridique : récemment un fille a cru me faire plaisir en disant :
"Quand j'ai su que j'allais venir te voir en spectacle
je me suis dis : ok, ce soir, je pose mon cerveau sur le côté, et je profite ! "
Ok... bah merci... euh... vu que te me fais cette remarque euh...
hyper agréable, euh... je me demandais
ton cerveau depuis, tu l'as récupéré ou pas ?
T'façon, que ce soit pour mon spectacle ou pour mes vidéos
je vous jure, dans la vie j'ai toujours le droit à des gens
qui me font des Faux Compliment comme ça.
J'en parle d'ailleurs un peu dans mon spectacle :
Moi, la dernière fois que je suis allé au restaurant,
le serveur il m'a reconnu par rapport aux vidéos
Il est venu me voir, sauf qu'il m'a dit un truc, j'ai pas trop kiffé
T'sais il est arrivé il a fait : "excusez-moi j'ai, j'ai un peu honte de l'avouer, j'ai un peu honte,
mais j'aime bien ce que vous faites " *rires*
Attends, c'est un compliment ou une insulte là ?
En plus de mon spectacle, dans ce DVD vous trouverez un petit documentaire
Des caméras m'ont suivi pendant deux ans dans cette petite salle de stand-up à Paris
qui s'appelle Le Paname
où je venais tous les soirs sept jours sur sept pour écrire mon spectacle et m'entraîner sur scène :
"Eh excuse-moi !". Et ça je le sais d'expérience que le mec veut pas s'excuser.
*rires*
C'est pas son projet initial, il a d'autres trucs en tête.
*verre qui tombe* Tu rembourses
Et euh... *rires*
Vous trouverez aussi dedans un bonus, où je me suis amusé aussi à répondre directement sur scène
aux questions du public
"Moi je voulais savoir si tu regardais tes vidéos"
*rires*
Ah non. Je euh... *rires* jamais vu
C'est pas mon style
J'suis pas abonné à ce genre de truc euh... moi c'est Squeezie, Squeezie à  mort !
Vous pourrez voir dans ce DVD un vlog spécialement dédié à ma tournée en Suisse.
euh... c'est-à-dire ma tournée suissesse
Ouais, on dit suissesse :
100% gavé, la puissance du pec !
*sonnerie d'alarme*
Y'a un pied de biche.
Eh imagine le mec il arrive et il fait : "Eh, qui c'est qui me cherche !"
*rires*
*Applaudissements et cris*
"C'est lui qui est tout petit en fait"
Y'a pas d'appareil photo donc là on fait ça pour euh... ou soit on se fait un câlin ! *rires*
Enfin dans ce DVD il y a un petit calepin
Hein, dessiné par un très mauvais dessinateur qui est moi-même.
Par exemple là c'est sensé être moi avec des yeux d'extraterrestres
*Musique d'extraterrestre*
Des croquis, des blagounettes
des souvenirs de tourné,
une tablature pour apprendre à jouer ma chanson sur scène
ouais, parce que y'a une chanson
Des petits jeux d'une difficulté extrême,
des quizz, et pleins de dessins très moches, mais rigolos
Alors vous trouverez mon DVD dans tous les magasins hyper culturels
hein comme Carrefour, LeClaire, Auchan. Appart peut être chez Castorama.
Et je crois que dedans, il y a un petit code de réduction pour venir me voir en décembre au Zénith.
Je peux l'avoir ? nan
Et bien sûr, il est dispo aussi en Blu-ray et en digital
sur toutes les plateformes, dont ma chaîne youtube.
Alors pour une fois, j'suis un petit peu sérieux, désoler mais,
s'il vous plaît, ne piratez pas mon spectacle,
NE PIRATEZ PAS MON SPECTACLE (grave et ralentis)
et enfin pour répondre à tous vos messages Twitter qui me demandaient quand est-ce que le DVD sort
Bah je vous donne la réponse, il sort... maintenant !
*Musique d'outro*